[Música]
[Aplausos]
en mi vida como entrenador
como conductor
han quedado grabadas cantidad de
imágenes
pero está
la bandera argentina por encima de la
bandera italiana y la bandera de los
eeuu
donde hay un podio olímpico
donde hay una medalla dorada
la sublime
y yo
en la tribuna
los entrenadores no tenemos acceso al
podio olímpico
los entrenadores no tenemos acceso a una
medalla
pero créanme desde el corazón
desde las lágrimas mismas
acompañando
al equipo pero sobre todo sintiéndome
parte
de lo que acabamos de lograr
tu vida se artista
tengo la certeza y seguramente voy a
seguir teniendo sé artesa de que hay un
medio
que se escribe con mayúscula
un nombre propio
que es el que nos transporta
a lugares inimaginables
que nos permite logros impensados
ese medio
es el equipo
lógico
hay que seleccionar y conformar el
equipo
la elección de personas con alto grado
de compromiso
humildemente inteligentes que saben
cuál es el camino cuáles son las
herramientas que hay que tomar para ir
en búsqueda de los objetivos que no
hemos planteado
que conoce y aprenden
que los resultados obtenidos son el
producto del trabajo colectivo
las mieles de la victoria los sabores
amargos de la derrota los tomamos como
propios
necesitábamos premisas seguramente todo
equipo la precisa
el todo
es mayor que la suma de las partes
él nos
por encima del yo
jugamos como entrenamos entonces
entrenamos como jugamos nadie juega
nadie juega con el esfuerzo de un
compañero
muchos equipos
están limitados
por el grado de compromisos que ellos
tienen
esos límites que le menciono pasan por
la capacidad de comprometerse el
compromiso una cosa curiosa que te
transforma un poquito los sueños en
realidad
satisfacción de trabajar juntos
orgullo de pertenecer
responsabilidades compartidas
nos miramos para los costados ni para
atrás
miramos para el frente
precisamos dentro del equipo
o desde lo personal
un elemento que me ayudó muchísimo
que se llama
percepción
desde el año 92 al año 2000
fui primer asistente técnico durante 8
años de la selección nacional de
básquetbol
yo lo titulé mis tiempos de trinchera
donde no tenía escenario tono no tenía
luces micrófono ni cámaras
consciente o inconscientemente estaba
apostado tratando de interpretar de
percibir
el verdadero pensamiento de las personas
que es a través
de sus actitudes
por eso
los invito
a que sean perceptivos cuando no estén
en el foco de la escena a mí me ayudó
muchísimo para tomar decisiones
importantísimas le diría casi
determinantes en mi carrera como
entrenador
todos los equipos
precisan
ser vulnerables al aprendizaje
humildemente inteligente mencioné
al inicio
grandes atletas grandes campeones de nba
euroliga
torneos de todo el mundo
tuvieron esa humildad inteligente de
bajarse un escalón tava nasa encima se
bajaron un escalón y se situaron a la
altura del equipo sin dejar de producir
lo que ellos están acostumbrado a
producir pero sabiendo y conociendo que
el talento no te garantice el éxito la
suma de capacidades individuales no te
garantiza la victoria
el talento sirve se le compartió si no
no
ese aprendizaje
en la vulnerabilidad que tienen los
individuos de aprender a aprender
leía por ahí donde hay alguien que
quiere aprender precisamos alguien que
sepa enseñar
cuando dejas de aprender
dejas de producir
es cierto
que el aprendizaje
va muy de la mano vamos a traer
una distinción
sumamente interesante
el saber escuchar
la escucha
válida
la comunicación la comunicación es lo
que le permite a la organización al
equipo crear un ambiente y una atmósfera
de confianza de respeto
confianza es el verdadero lubricante que
tiene cualquier equipo y permite que
fluyan
nuestra gente comprometida y nuestra
gente con talento
final liga nacional de básquetbol
atenas de córdoba
independiente de pico de la pampa
los pongo en situación las finales se
juegan a 7 juego y damos 3 a 3 y
definimos el último juego en el
polideportivo cerutti
nos traían mal no estaban cascoteando
mal no le encontraba vuelta
al partido
pasa marcelo milanesio creo que lo
conocen de razonó
y yo tuve el orgullo de conocerlo y de
disfrutarlo
pasa mar celemín y dice rubén porque no
tiramos y ensayamos la defensa que
hicimos hacer como una alternativa
agradezco profundamente haberme
permitido
utilizar esta distinción que es la
escucha es la que valida el habla la
escucha
esta distinción
y percibí
el contexto
percibí
quien me lo estaba diciendo
y toma una decisión
repetimos el juego atenas salió campeón
atenas salió campeón
no sé no sé si fue
por esa decisión pero sí sé que eso
cambió el rumbo de juego
por eso el aprendizaje va tan de la mano
van tan de la mano
con la escucha a ver
déjeme necesario alguna cosa
1 2 3 4 5 6 hacemos la imaginaria
del teatro ok vamos a dividir el teatro
en dos me van a ayudar con esto verdad
sí ok
lado derecho lado izquierdo por favor el
que pueda se para todo el teatro todos
por favor adelante recuerden de aquí
paras a un grupo y acá pasa otro grupo
cuando se apunta el lado derecho por
favor compasión
si la sílaba
cuando apunte el lado izquierdo de la
misma manera para
cuando vuelva que empezamos
[Aplausos]
se sientan por favor
de eso se trata
de eso se trata cuál fue mi intención
sacarlos de un lugar que ataca al
aprendizaje
de la zona de confort que estaban
sentados plácidamente en su silla lo
hice parar y curiosamente en pocos
segundos actuaron como un equipo uniendo
voluntades
respetando
los como porque todo equipo tiene que
tener un como
son las normas y las reglas que nos van
a permitir llegar a un determinado lugar
y todo equipo precisa aún que
qué es lo que nos moviliza qué es lo que
nos genera energía que son los objetivos
que nos planteamos los saque de la zona
de confort los puse en una situación de
aprendizaje sucede que los hice entonar
la palabra determinante coraje
es el valor que le va a permitir atacar
la zona de incertidumbre las horas
oscuras que te presenta el aprendizaje
porque porque nos puede atacar el ego
nos puede atacar el narciso a tener que
decir no sé
no puedo
esa palabra en cualquier organización la
precisamos tener a flor de piel
los equipos se muestran
en los grandes momentos
pero se construyen
diariamente
el éxito no es un acto
el éxito es un hábito no se dejen
confundir con vídeos de 15 segundos
enlatados donde van a los sacan exitosos
tienen que recorrer un camino
el éxito
del día lunes
cuando entró a la oficina cuando entré a
la universidad
cuando voy al club entrenar o cuando
manejo el taxi
hay comienzo a ser exitoso
ahí empiezo a vivir mis cambios de
conducta amplió mi campo de acción
entonces yo sumo éxito del día lunes del
martes del miércoles cuando tenga que
jugar el día domingo o el día sábado o
tenga que dar un examen
voy a estar preparados
no voy a estar listo totalmente
diferente una cosa están listos y otra
cosa estar
preparados
los equipos
son atacados por un elemento que pega
duro
que se llama adversidades
lesión de ginóbili semifinal del torneo
del mundo
lección de montecchia preolímpico de
puerto rico- lección de oberto semifinal
del juego olímpico y otras muchas más
pero esta moza adversidad tiene una
curiosidad si estamos preparados
despierta talento que en época de
prosperidad parece que tuviesen dormido
esa no va a tener la habilidad
te sacamos
la mirada del foco donde nosotros
queremos llegar no se lo permitamos
hemos estado
hablando de
compromiso
hemos estado hablando de humildad
inteligente hemos estado hablando de
confianza
al respecto
de aprendizajes de saber escuchar
qué peso mayor tiene un equipo que la de
tener valores compartidos
les cuento una sensación
yo los veía jugar
a través trata de interpretar sus
actitudes como habíamos hablado los veía
jugar
y esos sentían placer
y hacer más grande al que tenían al lado
cuando ustedes logran eso
dentro de su organización de su equipo
están para grandes cosas
nada más nada más valioso que el
verdadero capital que tiene cualquier
organización los valores compartidos
qué suerte
qué suerte que tienes rubén
todos los años un título
si le digo plano claro que tengo suerte
tengo mucha suerte yo me doy cuenta que
cuando más trabajo más suerte tengo
paso 1 rápido por ahí
solo
llego más rápido
pero no te das cuenta
que juntos
juntos llegamos más lejos
por eso
quieren subirse al equipo
quieren subirse al éxito
o quieren ser
personalmente imprescindibles
[Aplausos]
[Música]